GABRIELA FERRARA: In this video,
we will share some good news
with you.
We finally have
external primary server
that we will allow you
to migrate your MySQL
server to Google Cloud
Platform with minimal downtime.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We know there are two
ways to migrate data,
and this talk talks
about both but shows
you the new feature,
the replication
for an external
primary intercloud SQL.
The traditional way involves
a variable downtime migration,
which could take from minutes
to hours or even weeks,
depending on the
size of your data.
This approach usually have
the following configuration.
First, an instance of your
database, your primary,
needs to disconnect
from your application
so the data doesn't change.
Then, export this
data to a SQL file
or CSV using tools like
MySQL DAP or PG-DAC.
After that, provision
a new instance
and import the file
exporter to this new server.
At this point, connect
to the application
again so the downtime is over.
If you can afford
the downtime, this
is the simplest way of
doing a database migration.
If you can't afford
that much downtime,
there is a different
way using replication.
On this approach,
your application
is connecting to an
instance, your primary,
and all the changes are
being sent to a new instance,
a replica, elsewhere.
Replication will
catch up, but you
need to stop the application
from continuing writing
to the existing instance.
Once that is completed, the
replication is also stopped,
and the new instance is
promoted to be the new primary.
With the promotion
process completed,
you can now point your
application to read and write
to the new instance.
Watch this session
and don't miss out
this feature in action.
Watch as I migrate the database
from a single instance within
a common scenario-- running
a WordPress application with
Apache and MySQL--
to a new scenario where the
database is fully managed
by Cloud SQL, leaving
the previous instance to
only serve the application.
For more
in-the-trenches details,
check out the full talk
and follow the steps.
Also, don't forget to subscribe
to our channel for more
great Next Rewind content.
[MUSIC PLAYING]